ربما تكون جو سوينتون مبتدئة في الملاكمة
لكنها تتأرجح بشكل كبير في خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي وتقاتل
الرسالة الواضحة التي أرسلها الناخبون إلى
وستمنستر في عام 2016
بنسبة 52٪ إلى 48٪ على الصعيد الوطني لصالح
سوينسون ،
زعيم الديمقراطيين الأحرار الوسطيين ، الذي
يسعى للاستفادة منه.
القضية المركزية للحملة الانتخابية خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
والتي تغازل 48٪ الذين صوتوا
للبقاء بالتعهد بإلغاء خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
تمامًا ، وإلغاء المادة 50 ،
لا نقاش ، لا تصويت ، هذه
انتخابات ديمقراطية الآن ويمكن للناس
الاختيار وإذا كانوا يريدون التوقف
يكسرها كديمقراطيين ليبراليين ، نحن
ندافع عن ما نعتقد أنه
الموقف الصحيح ،
هل لا تحترم 52 ٪ من الأشخاص الذين
صوتوا لمغادرة الاتحاد الأوروبي أو هل
تعتقد أنك تعرف أفضل من أنني
أحترمهم وأنا  لا أوافق باحترام
مع حزب Swensons يقوم باستطلاع رأي ثالث بعيد على
المستوى الوطني ولكنه يأمل في القيام بعمل أفضل
بعد إبرام اتفاق مع حزبين أصغر من Pro
يظلان حزبيين اتفقا على عدم
الوقوف ضد كل منهما  أخرى في 60
دائرة انتخابية جميعها لتوحيد
التصويت المتبقي على مضيف برنامجه الإذاعي
المتصل iandale يحصل بانتظام على مذنب من
الناخبين الذين يشعرون أنها المؤسسة السياسية
والنخب في البلاد هم من يتخذون القرارات
وليس هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين خسروا الاستفتاء لا يمكنهم
يتحملون ذلك حقًا ، فهم يعتقدون أن الأشخاص الذين صوتوا
لصالح خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي كانوا عنصريين غبيين ،
بغض النظر عن أي شيء ،
ولم يتصالحوا مع هذه النتيجة ،
وأخشى ألا أعتقد أنهم سيفعلون ذلك أبدًا ،
ولا يعتقد سوينسون ديل فقط
لقد أمضى السياسيون من جميع الأطياف السنوات الثلاث
الماضية فقط وهم يتظاهرون بالمضي قدمًا في
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ، ما يفعلونه في الواقع هو
تخريب amok Recei وهي
لعبة خطيرة للغاية
يلعبونها ولكنهم لم يعدوا دقيقين للغاية ، والبعض الآخر
أكثر دقة.  أكثر من دقة الآخرين ،
يبدو أنه لم يعد مطلوبًا سوى
حزب واحد محافظ كبير كما وعد
بمتابعة خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ، حيث
تعهد الحزب الوطني الاسكتلندي بالبقاء
وحزب العمال المعارض.  إجراء
استفتاء ثان ،
لذا في حين أن احتمالات سوينسون في أن تصبح رئيسة
للوزراء طويلة ، فإنها لا تحتاج إلى
الفوز المباشر لعرقلة خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
سكوت ماكلين سي إن إن لندن
[تصفيق]